cinco de mayo celebrations who better to
talk about it than el guapo
jc in downtown that's right jp
the boss the boss is downtown you guys
we've got a celebration happening at
container park and this is james
he's the general manager people just
joining us right now real quick what can
they expect tonight well they got 250
tacos of el pastor and pollo
and six dollar margaritas at pinterest
tacos custom featured tequila drinks
we've got a mechanical bull from fighter
9 and mariachis from 9 to 11.
okay the mariachi band's gonna be
amazing i'm looking at the mechanical
bull i'm gonna get on this thing uh in
the four o'clock hour is there tip to
riding
the mechanical bull uh kendall he's from
texas like you what's the trick to
riding a mechanical bullet and center of
balance when it's time to let go let go
let go when it's time to let go kendall
have you ridden a ball before no i never
have what kind of texan am i
hey you know guys got me calling me on
my phone
i was paying attention jesse
yeah thank you guys i'm in hey by the
way no
tell me yeah it's handsome the boss
is handsome yeah you're yeah i mean
good looking oh my gosh
oh hold on timeout if the studio is
blowing up people people are asking are
you single
correct them yeah uh oh
no him yeah oh people don't know people
want to know if he's single
oh man so no
you know i tell you what guys hold on
one second
it's cinco de mayo so what what's what's
in this margarita right here let's see
if i can taste exactly
what's in this one yeah we have 30
seconds
the elf that's called tequila
by our awesome
happy cinco de mayo